Año 2020, todos los países del mundo van
a sufrir una enorme recesión por la pandemia
del Nuevo SARS CoronaVirus 2 ¿Todos?
¡No!
Hay un club selecto de países que, en principio,
van a salir beneficiados.
Y todo apunta a que el mayor ganador de esta
pandemia va a ser, nada más y nada menos
que VIETNAM.
Ya lo sé: la primera palabra que os viene
a la cabeza cuando oís Vietnam es “Guerra”:
la Guerra de Vietnam.
En los años 60, miles de jóvenes estadounidenses
se marcharon a este país con sus botas militares
y sus fusiles ¡Pero la historia es muy irónica!
Porque ahora, 75 años después de todo aquello,
los nietos de aquellos jóvenes vuelven a
Vietnam... aunque esta vez van vestidos de
corbata, armados con tablets y portátiles.
Sí, amigos de VisualPolitik, Vietnam está
de moda.
Podríamos decir que es la nueva China.
De hecho, muchas empresas que tenían fábricas
en China ya están moviendo buena parte del
negocio a Vietnam.
Todo esto ya estaba pasando antes del CoronaVirus.
Pero la pandemia ha acelerado esta tendencia.
Y no hablamos de empresas pequeñas.
Atentos.
Samsung traslada parte de su producción de
smartphones a Vietnam debido al CoronaVirus
Y sí, buena parte de este cambio se debe
a que Vietnam ha sido uno de países que mejor
a gestionado la pandemia ¡Habéis oído bien!
Aquí en VisualPolitik os hemos contado el
ejemplo de países como Corea del Sur, Taiwan
o República Checa.
Seguramente pocos habréis oído hablar de
Vietnam como ejemplo de gestión de la pandemia.
Pero lo cierto es que lo han hecho sorprendentemente
bien.
Hablamos de un país relativamente pobre,
con más de 95 millones de habitantes que
comparte frontera con China ¿Cuántas muertes
diríais que han tenido?
Pues la respuesta es 0.
Tal cual.
En el momento en el que hacemos este vídeo,
Vietnam no ha tenido ningún fallecido por
Covid-19.
Es más, uno de los vídeos que ha sacado
el gobierno con información de salud pública
se ha hecho viral.
Y no es para menos ¡Echad un vistazo!
¡Pero toda esta historia va mucho más allá
del CoronaVirus!
Vietnam lleva décadas creciendo y atrayendo
empresas.
De hecho, hay un dato muy curioso.
Vietnam es una dictadura comunista, muy parecida
a China.
Sin embargo, la sociedad vietnamita es la
más partidaria del libre mercado del mundo.
Al menos, eso es lo que dice una encuesta
que hizo el Pew Research Center en el 2015.
Y tiene bastante sentido.
Cada vez hay más empresas que se establecen
en Vietnam.
Fábricas de muebles, de ropa, de zapatos...
Para que os hagáis una idea, 1 de cada 2
zapatillas de ADIDAS tienen la etiqueta Made
in Taiwan.
Y esto es curioso porque hace 10 años, la
mitad de la producción de Adidas estaba en
China.
El cambio ha sido rapidísimo ¡Y ya sé lo
que me vais a decir muchos!
A ver, Fonseca, no te emociones porque tampoco
estás dando buenas noticias.
Todos lo sabemos, la industria textil no paga
buenos sueldos.
Ahí está el caso de Bangladesh.
Bangladesh es la meca de la industria de la
moda.
Sin embargo, llevan décadas anclados en la
pobreza.
Y sí, tenéis razón.
La industria textil es una industria de poco
valor añadido.
Pero, a diferencia de Bangladesh, Vietnam
ya está empezando a fabricar tecnología.
Los productos tecnológicos si tienen valor
añadido y sueldos mucho más altos.
Y diréis ¿Made in Vietnam?
¿Qué clase de tecnología se hace en Vietnam?
Pues seguramente, una que estaréis usando
muchos ahora mismo.
Apple anuncia que ha empezado a fabricar algunos
de sus AirPods en Vietnam
Para que os hagáis una idea, en los últimos
10 años, el PIB de Vietnam se ha duplicado.
Y este dinero se ha traducido en mejoras reales
para la vida de todos los vietnamitas.
Para que os hagáis una idea, a diferencia
de los Chinos, el 97% de los Vietnamitas tiene
cobertura sanitaria.
Es cierto que los sueldos todavía son bajos.
Pero también es cierto que hay viviendas
de protección oficial y toda clase de programas
para reducir la pobreza.
Ciudades como Ho Chi Minh City o Saigon se
están cubriendo de rascacielos.
Pero los barrios pobres tienen muchas mejores
infraestructuras que en otros países como
Bangladesh o la India.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Qué está pasando
en Vietnam?
¿Cómo es posible que un país que estuvo
en guerra con Estados Unidos se haya integrado
tan bien en el mercado mundial?
¿Cómo es posible que vayan a salir tan beneficiados
del CoronaVirus?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
¡GOOD MORNING, VIETNAM!
Pocas guerras han inspirado más películas
y más canciones que la Guerra de Vietnam.
Todos hemos visto APOCALIPSIS NOW, hemos escuchado
a los CREEDENCE (y... si no lo habéis hecho,
no sé que hacéis con vuestra vida, honestamente).
Sin embargo, todo eso es la visión estadounidense
de la guerra.
Lo que seguro que no conocéis tan bien es
cómo vivieron la guerra los Vietnamitas.
Y, creedme, es una historia mucho más triste
de lo que parece.
Sí, es cierto, Vietnam ganó la guerra.
Pero el país quedó completamente destruido.
Se calcula que perdieron la vida entre 1 millón
y 3 millones de vietnamitas.
Y a diferencia de la II Guerra Mundial, Vietnam
no tuvo ningún plan Marshall.
Obviamente, Estados Unidos no les iba a ayudar
a reconstruirse.
Y la Unión Soviética tenía cosas más importantes
de las que preocuparse que de un país que
ni siquiera sabían dónde estaba en el mapa.
Por si esto fuera poco, el Gobierno de Vietnam
tampoco era un ejemplo de gestión responsable.
Ho Chi Minh había muerto durante la guerra.
Y sus sucesores hacían que el mismísimo
Stalin pareciera un político moderado.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en pocos años,
el Partido Comunista Vietnamita expropió
todas las tierras de cultivo.
Y metió en campos de reeducación a más
de 250.000 survietnamitas ¡Pero aquí no
termina la cosa!
Muchos pensaréis que todos los países comunistas
se llevaban bien ¿verdad?
Pues os equivocáis.
Durante los años 80, Vietnam y Camboya entraron
en guerra.
Camboya estaba apoyada por China.
Así que China terminó atacando a Vietnam.
En otras palabras: que si la guerra con Estados
Unidos no era poco, los Vietnamitas sufrieron
dos guerras por el precio de una.
Como os podéis imaginar, en el año 1986,
el país estaba hecho un auténtico Ecce Homo:
hambruna, hiperinflación y pobreza extrema.
Y ahí es cuando el partido comunista convocó
un congreso.
Al igual que pasó con China, los políticos
más jóvenes le dijeron esto a los más viejos.
...hemos cometido errores debido al infantilismo
de izquierda y el idealismo (...) Estos errores
se han manifestado en (mantener) el mecanismo
de gestión económica de centralización
burocrática. –Truong Chinh, político comunista
Vietnamita
Y así es como nació el programa DOI MOI:
la gran reforma Vienamita.
Básicamente, el DOI MOI fue algo así como
la apertura de China pero en esteroides.
A diferencia de China, Vietnam no hizo zonas
económicas especiales.
Directamente, en 10 años cambiaron todo el
país de arriba abajo.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en 1986, tener
una empresa, aunque fuera una granja familiar,
estaba prohibido. 10 años más tarde, NIKE
ya estaba abriendo sus primeras fábricas
en suelo vietnamita.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando ¡Pues
bien!
¡Esta historia ya la hemos visto!
Básicamente, es lo mismo que pasó en China
¿Verdad?
¿Qué le hace especial a Vietnam?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
CÓMO CHINA, PERO BAJO EN ARANCELES
Si tienes una empresa y quieres abrir una
fábrica, Vietnam tiene dos ventajas imbatibles
respecto a China: sueldos más bajos y población
más joven.
Ya lo explicamos en otros vídeos, la política
de Hijo Único en China ha traído una sociedad
muy envejecida.
En Vietnam hicieron lo contrario: el Gobierno
dio toda clase de ayudas para que las familias
tuvieran muchos hijos.
Como consecuencia, casi todos los vietnamitas
están en edad de trabajar.
Por otra parte, los sueldos chinos cada vez
son más altos.
A día de hoy, un trabajador de Shenzhen cobra
un sueldo equivalente a uno de Hungría, por
poner un ejemplo ¿Qué suele pasar en estos
casos?
Pues que China se especializa en tareas de
alto valor añadido.
Es decir, empiezan a producir sus propios
smartphones, sus propios drones y sus propios
coches eléctricos.
Cosas que requieren trabajadores con estudios.
Y los productos que requieren trabajos más
mecánicos se van a Vietnam.
Eso explica noticias como esta.
El gigante de la fabricación de hilos, Texhong,
invertirá 500 millones de dólares en Vietnam
¡Exacto!
El primer paso del desarrollo de Vietnam fue
el de convertirse en la China de China.
Por el momento, nada nuevo que no hayamos
visto en otros países.
Sin embargo, las cosas cambiaron en el año
2018.
Concretamente, el 5 de julio de 2018.
La guerra comercial de Trump con China está
oficialmente declarada
En ese momento es cuando Trump empezó a poner
aranceles a los productos Chinos.
China respondió con más aranceles a productos
estadounidenses.
Y, entre medias, muchas empresas que tenían
fábricas en suelo Chino empezaron a plantearse
¿Dónde nos vamos ahora?
Y la respuesta estaba más que clara: Vietnam.
Está al lado de China.
De hecho, muchas empresas han burlado las
aranceles exportando las mercancías desde
Vietnam.
Por ejemplo, imaginad que sois un productor
de acero Chino.
Si mandáis unas vigas de acero directamente
a Estados Unidos, tenéis que pagar un arancel
del 25% ¡Pero hay una trampa!
Podéis mandar la viga al puerto de HAI PHONG.
Le ponéis la etiqueta Made in Vietnam y ¡Tachan!
La podéis mandar a Los Ángeles libre de
aranceles.
Por supuesto, esta práctica, lo que se llama
el trans shipping, está empezando a prohibirse.
Pero muchos exportadores han estado haciendo
trampas como esta hasta hace poco tiempo.
¡Pero no sólo hablamos de trampas!
También hay muchos negocios legítimos que
están empezando a ver a Vietnam como su nueva
China.
Y ya no hablamos de fábricas de zapatos sino
de cosas mucho más jugosas.
Google translada la producción de su smartphone
PIXEL de China a Vietnam
Por supuesto que esta no es la primera fábrica
de smarphones que se monta en Vietnam.
Nokia ya tenía fábricas desde hace años.
Pero este es sólo un ejemplo.
Samsung, Apple y muchas empresas más ya están
haciendo lo mismo.
Incluso ya están surgiendo marcas de móvil
vietnamitas.
Y lo cierto es que Vietnam tiene muchas ventajas
políticas.
En cierto modo, podríamos decir que están
en el mismo lugar donde estaba China antes
de que llegara Xi Jinping: un país que cada
vez se abre más al mundo.
Una dictadura comunista, sí, pero donde casi
todas las decisiones se toman de forma colegiada
en el Partido.
Dicho de otra forma: a día de hoy, Xi Jinping
es el líder indiscutible de China.
Tiene poder casi ilimitado.
En Vietnam tienen un secretario general del
partido comunista, un primer ministro, una
presidenta del partido y una asamblea comunista.
Por supuesto que todos pertenecen al mismo
partido, pero unos se controlan a todos.
Sigue siendo una dictadura, pero mucho más
suave que la de China.
Y eso se nota en pequeños detalles.
Por ejemplo, los vietnamitas pueden ver vídeos
de YouTube.
Evidentemente, muchos vídeos están censurados.
Pero la plataforma es totalmente legal.
Es más, hay YouTubers vietnamitas.
Probablemente incluso este vídeo se pueda
ver en Vietnam.
Lo mismo pasa con Facebook, Google o cualquier
otra empresa de internet.
Para que os hagáis una idea, mientras China
es cada vez más proteccionista, Vietnam está
haciendo cosas como esta.
EU-Vietnam: el Consejo da la luz verde finalmente
al acuerdo de Libre Comercio
El acuerdo de libre comercio entre la Unión
Económica Euroasiática y Vietnam entra en
efecto el 5 de octubre de 2016
Pero todo esto es lo que estaba ocurriendo
ANTES de la Pandemia.
Sin embargo, en este vídeo hemos dicho que
íbamos a hablar de cómo Vietnam es el gran
beneficiado por el CoronaVirus ¿Verdad?
Pues ahora mismo vamos a ver el por qué.
LOS GANADORES DEL CORONAVIRUS
Ya lo decíamos al principio: por mucho que
esté creciendo, Vietnam sigue siendo un país
pobre.
Si China tiene una renta per cápita de 20.000
dólares, Vietnam está en torno a los 8600.
Sin embargo, el Gobierno ha conseguido garantizar
cobertura sanitaria al 97% de la población.
A eso hay que unirle que el Gobierno, pese
a ser una dictadura, ha sido muy transparente
con todo lo que se refiere al CoronaVirus.
Desde el primer día, lanzaron toda clase
de campañas para informar a los ciudadanos:
por qué tenían que llevar mascarillas, lavarse
las manos y evitar salir de casa.
Conclusión: a día de hoy, Vietnam tiene
334 casos confirmados de Covid-19 y 0 muertes.
Tal cual como lo oís.
Todo esto teniendo en cuenta que comparten
frontera con China es digno de un aplauso
¡Pero no sólo hablamos de salud!
También hablamos de economía.
La estrategia China + 1 podría mantener la
cadena de valor más robusta
Básicamente, si algo hemos aprendido con
la pandemia es que no es bueno depender de
un único país que fabrique cosas ¡Y no
sólo hablamos de teléfonos móviles!
Por ejemplo, el 95% del Ibuprofeno que se
consume en Estados Unidos viene de China.
Algo parecido pasa con otras cosas como las
mascarillas.
Claro, luego llega algo como una pandemia
y toda la producción se va a freír churros.
Los vamos a explicar más a fondo en otro
vídeo.
Pero quedaos con este concepto: China + 1.
Es decir; vale, tenemos un proveedor en China
¡Pero vamos a tener otro, en otro país!
¡Por si acaso!
Las empresas ya están tomando nota.
Y los gobiernos también.
Japón reserva 243.500 millones de yenes para
ayudar a las empresas a sacar la producción
de China
Todo esto explica durante todo este 2020 estemos
viendo tantas empresas moviendo parte de su
producción a Vietnam.
Desde Google hasta Microsoft.
Si os dais cuenta, ya no estamos hablando
de Nike ni de Adidas.
Es decir, que ya no hablamos de talleres con
mano de obra barata.
Cada vez más, estamos viendo empresas tecnológicas
que abren fábricas por esta zona.
Eso significa trabajos mejor cualificados
y mejor pagados.
Y ya sé lo que pensaréis muchos ¡Oh Dios
mío!
Vietnam es el paraíso.
Ahora todas esas empresas que en su día se
fueron a China van a ir en manada a Vietnam
¡Pues no!
¡Por supuesto que no!
De entrada, Vietnam todavía tiene muchos
problemas.
Pensadlo bien: China lleva décadas siendo
la fábrica del mundo.
Eso significa que, a día de hoy, es fácil
encontrar trabajadores cualificados.
Gente que ha estudiado en universidades y
que sabe cómo producir bienes de alto valor
añadido.
Además, China ya tiene unas infraestructuras
de lujo y proveedores de todo tipo.
A Vietnam le faltan muchos años para llegar
a ese nivel.
Y, por supuesto, otros países como Tailandia
también tienen muchas posibilidades.
En otras palabras, Vietnam necesita invertir
mucho más en educación y en construir carreteras.
Además, no hay que olvidar que todavía es
una dictadura, con todo el riesgo político
que eso conlleva.
Pero, en estos momentos, sí podemos decir
que cuando todo el mundo se enfrenta a una
recesión Vietnam es una de las pocas excepciones
que va a seguir creciendo.
Así que ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
¿Será esta la década de Vietnam?
¿Cuánto tardaremos en ver turistas vietnamitas
paseando por nuestras ciudades?
¿Puede Vietnam llegar a ser una democracia...
o seguirán los pasos de China?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas, así que suscribíos
a VisualPolitik y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.